hi everyone uh last talk last day uh
thank you all for staying here uh I know
all of your brain is full of lot of
information so hopefully you can get
something out of this talk as well
so as Taylor uh introduced I'm Margie
I'm engineering lead at Freeville and
today I'm here to talk about a very
important topic in the world of AD tech
industry
so as we all know the edtech industry
has exploded our Publishers and
advertisers are trying to reach
consumers on various screens
Ott CTV connected TV the mobile desktop
and many more
they're trying to leverage new
technology uh to to to get to the more
like a personalized and relevant ads to
the consumers
uh the billions of dollars are
transacted uh in a technology called the
real-time bidding
and the key enabler for the real-time
bidding is the real-time data
for example a brand can Target their
product using a mobile location of your
mobile phone
retailer shop will use real-time
interaction on your website on a website
to tailor their targeting
so accessing this data in real time and
acting in real time is very crucial for
this industry
however uh there are so many events
generated every second it becomes
challenging uh to access this data in
real time
so today I'm here to talk about some of
the key challenges that we are facing in
our uh data team and how we have uh
solved for that
so before that who are we
um we are part of Comcast
we which uh particularly Comcast
advertising which is a number one seller
of video advertising in U.S
at free will we serve ads we serve ads
in the premium content
um our some of our biggest customers are
nbcu Hulu dish atnt and many more that
are listed here
in aggregate we serve more than 90
percent of uh and aggregate we serve 90
of top media companies in U.S and uh in
international
so just to give you a number we serve
daily on average 2 billion video
Impressions through our Free Will system
beeswax so if Beeswax is a buy side
platform of free will
uh they become a part of Free Will about
it two years ago
they are industry experts in building
the demand side platform for the premium
programmatic
so what does that mean that this means
that we help advertisers buy the
inventory that adds loss in most
efficient way through our platform
uh we solve this challenge by in-house
implementation that is focusing on
transparency flexibility and control
so we settled to some of the brands like
indeed Uber our uh the tech media
companies agencies and some of the oems
so before we dive into our data platform
let's do basics of real-time bidding
more like ad Tech one-on-one
so a user go on a website
uh website loads the ad slot will come
and of course publisher wants to
monetize on this ad so they will reach
out to their advertising uh so their
monetizing partner ad exchanges more
like a stock exchanges like it's similar
to Stock Exchange
so
ad exchange will send a bid request to
many demand side platforms so in this
case it will come to a beeswax
bid request will contains a lot of
information like uh the size of the
placement type of the placement whom it
is going to serve to where is it going
to served all this thing comes in a
protocol open rtb protobuf that's a
protocol that used for the uh real-time
bidding
now DSP will decide if and what to bid
on this bid request
and then sends that bid response to uh
ad exchange that's what the auction
takes place
and if we win the auction
uh uh the ad the the ad will be sent to
the publisher and seen by a user
so this is like the the demand and
Supply right so this is inventory ad
slots are the inventories that's a
supply and nads space is more like a
demand for those supplies again this is
like very high level of what happens in
real-time bidding and today in this talk
we'll focus on this hexagon uh uh the
the beeswax the demand side platform
so what happens after the ad is served
when Once the ad is turned the event
trackers get fired so we'll uh and and
it tracks all the information uh like
impression clicks conversions and it all
those events will comes to our event
server so in this case it will come to
beeswax event server
it will update some of the information
like budget so you don't overspend
frequency cap pacing segments so you can
use the same information for retargeting
or exclude targeting
but all those events will come to now
through the event server it will come to
the beeswax data platform uh and that's
where all the magic happens and it will
be served to our Downstream which is for
reporting or the Raw event logs and many
more
again we'll focus in this purple box
here today the beeswax data platform
that's where uh that's where we're gonna
talk about more
um
I just want to give like different type
of event types that we have so bid
request again like I I don't I haven't
put all the parameters in this event but
just for simplifying it so bid request
will have a request ID and the creative
information
if you win on the bid request it will
have a winning price
um associated with that
and as I said once the event tracker get
fired it will have all the events like
impression clicks so it will have click
URL the timestamp of the click uh event
type and at the end of the day we want
to make a complete record so associate
like match join all those
uh events to all the way up to the bid
request
so I want to start with giving some
infrastructure highlight and showing you
I want to show some numbers uh
to just like to show what what scale uh
that we are uh dealing with so like this
gives you number on every second every
day every year
so our event service is 2.5 million of
content requests every second
and from there like half a million of
those uh events will come to a data
platform because you're not going to bid
on every single auctions uh that comes
to your event server that comes down to
10 billion event logs every day
we see this number grow every year uh
even on the data storage side our our we
are growing year over year
so I would like to talk about how our
small team of data engineering is
um dealing with the scale on another
team
so
our data platform is a robust system
that collects organize and delivers data
uh one uh and and one of the most
important consideration in working with
the real-time bidding data platform is
building a data pipeline that
processes uh data processes events for
bid wins and all the associated uh like
clicks and conversion everything so we
have about
50 plus data Pipelines
that that generates data for raw log
delivery as well as our our reporting
our our platform is built for the
scalable for the scalable infrastructure
and optimize for cost so we have various
uh traffic during the during the day
versus
um in the night so we should we should
be able to scale up and down right so we
architected on the AWS part instances we
have Auto scaling we are on multi-region
all those fun stuff
we have diverse set of
data stores so aerospike is our key
Value Store snowflake as our data
warehouse
Kinesis S3 and many more
we also have a diverse set of data
offering so here I'm dividing uh our
data product offering into two side one
is a raw log delivery on the left hand
side and on the right hand side is uh
more on the reporting
so we have a streaming log delivery we
have uh the batch log delivery we do
data sharing through Snowflake and on
the reporting side we have some new uh
reports built on our UI but we also
provide API so customers can build their
own reports without even logging into
our UI
um we have real-time bidding stats that
gives you information like am I winning
or bidding uh uh uh on and like how my
campaign is performing in real time
so why would customer cares about this
uh event log data right so it uh even
log data provides a transparency uh into
the campaign
uh and unlike any other DSP beeswax
provides uh beeswax provides uh you can
have like unfiltered stream of
um this events as if like you are
building your own bidder so that's what
people are using it so they are they if
if you have a data team if you have data
engineering team or a data science team
you can build your own bidding algorithm
and bring it to the beeswax platform
to to to optimize your campaign you can
also use this data to join with any
other in-house like first party data
that you have that will help you uh like
more like a granular level reporting you
can use it for forecasting
um and and many other use cases
we also have a pretty diverse like this
is just like gives you an example of
with different types of logs different
format different delivery Cadence I'm
not going to go over this table but it
just gives you the variety of ways that
we are providing our uh logs to the
customers
we have uh a reporting platform
um
any data team will be supporting so we
have like a data visualization tools uh
campaign manager can come to our
um
site and
get like more a lot more insight into
the campaign
uh
I wanna I'm gonna go over like all the
different kind of reports we have but
just want to talk about this one Niche
reporting that we have which helps a
power user come and say okay how my bid
my life off bid uh is doing
um before I even win or lose that bid
right so there are like different stages
uh that bid can go through before it
decides to lose and lose a bit or you
win a bid so you you can match a Target
so if you are trying to Target
um a customers like uh uh let's say 30
to 35 age group mail uh are you are you
matching that Target is your size of the
uh placement matching so diff a
different stage you want to make sure
that it helps you answer the questions
like do we have enough Supply are we
winning enough are we are we bidding
enough uh how do we change our strategy
uh which makes it very powerful uh
reporting for our uh customers
all right so
I think
I'm gonna slow down a little bit because
now I want to walk through our data
architecture so with data flow like how
those events are flowing through our
system
uh from event server to all the way uh
to the reporting
um uh and and and uh the event logs data
so
here uh the each box is a different type
of so the blue the yellow box is more
like ingestion uh Pink Box is for our
stream writer uh and blue box is our
data warehouse
uh the events as we as we talked earlier
uh the event trackers uh when the event
tracker fires the events are coming to
the event server right so clicks
impression conversion along with all the
auctions and bids
that comes to the event server and flows
through our Kinesis stream
Kinesis stream is just like fail it just
gives us the safe handling of the events
now this events flows through our it
doesn't have the uh
pointer but it flows through the
uh it flows through our consumer
application
which is uh
it's basically a Java uh application
written using um KCl Library provided by
Amazon
um it helps us write like distributed uh
application without any overhead
so consumer application is responsible
for reading uh formatting
and and routing all those events to
various endpoints
one of the biggest end points is our S3
bucket so it's internal S3 buckets we
have as well as
um external S3 buckets which is they
have we have like about 100 more than
100 S3 buckets configured uh where we
write uh this raw events uh to work for
our consumer customers
the consumer application
um is also writing to our to
internal and external Kinesis streams so
internal Kinesis stream is a real-time
status Kinesis stream that just gives
you real time
um reporting on Mi winning orbiting
which was displayed on our UI
uh the stream writer Kinesis stream is
responsible for joining those events and
writing to our customers using HTTP
endpoints
along with all these places uh
consumer application
also writes to the Aerospace cluster
aerospike cluster is
responsible for joining these events in
real time so as we said we want to make
sure that each bid request
has Associated if there is a conversion
or if there's an impression that is
served for that bid request or there is
a click for that bid request and we are
joining those in real time in aerospike
consumer application also writes to uh
meta markets and imply which are just
the high performing analytical Tool uh
that just request our customers would uh
required for uh for their real-time
Analytics
uh now it's coming down to our
uh the data warehousing side
so we use snowflake as our data
warehouse
we
uh and and we use snowpipe for our data
ingestion so every time a consumer
application rights to an S3 bucket the
snow pipe will pick it uh will write
that to uh uh
our warehouse
we have uh
uh did a pipeline so that just basically
uh Aggregates and transformed this event
clocks data and those uh those pipelines
have returned into python orchestrated
by airflow uh which are which will be
and make those pre-aggregated tables
available for our Downstream use cases
like dashboarding and uh
antenna is over data sharing uh through
snowflake uh and redash is just like an
internal tool that we use for querying
um yeah so that's that's like our how
our data is how our bid is Flowing from
event server to uh uh to through the
through over all the way to our
reporting
um
so I talked about
as you can see like we are using a lot
of tools uh in our uh in our data
platform but I wanna I wanna talk about
like why some of the choices that we
have made when we decided to Pivot uh
and how it's working out for us
so
this is a pillar for our data platform
right it's a high quality product the
modern architecture and the cost
efficiency
but we work on some of the guiding
principle uh so one of the key guiding
principle is scalability and efficiency
so as I shown the numbers uh uh prior
like we are we are seeing the year over
year growth so we should be able to
scale with that growth without
incurring major cost
we focus on creating defensible
differentiator
so create genuine value for the
customers
and for data team it's basically
supporting our customers needs in
whichever way they uh they can work best
with this data that we have
we build attack that's what we are good
at and we are okay to buy everything
else so focus our engineering uh
bandwidth on creating the
differentiators and Trust uh the experts
in the industry who has built those Tool
uh for long and they are in the market
for a long time
also time to the market is very critical
uh factor in success to our data
platform
uh
we quickly develop tests get the
feedback and and and and and move on
um that's that's kind of like philosophy
uh off of our data platform
so I'm just gonna talk about some of the
tools uh that we have and what was our
like Choice uh like first choice and uh
and why we may move to this uh the tools
that we have
so AWS Kinesis uh as I said uh AWS is
like a streaming application
our first choice was Kafka but having a
small team we realized that we need to
move to something that is like easily
scalable uh without uh having a lot of
Engineers so Kinesis is fully managed
service it's pretty easy to set up uh
like couple of clicks you are up and
running uh your uh
streaming in couple of days
we use aerospike as our
quick like a fast real-time nosql
database and this this will help our
consumer application uh which is written
in uh Java and KCl becoming a stateless
and the aerospike will hold all those
events for a certain number of time uh
uh and and provides like exceptional
performance
for our application
we use snowflake as our data warehouse
so our we started with redshift
um but then quickly pivot to snowflake
just for some of the uh obvious features
that snowflake was providing at that
time which is like distinguishes compute
from Storage uh pretty high security uh
we there uh their secure sharing is
something that we don't have to make
multiple copy of our reviews we can
share our data using the snowflake
secure sharing
also uh there's no pipe so ingestion is
like pretty uh easy uh you can use
snowpipe to ingest
um our data events to the data warehouse
view looker for our reporting so again
this is another the tool that we uh
have we selected because we we just
realized that we won't be able to scale
for customers demand we had in-house UI
uh which was just like great like I
think it was on react uh and creating
reports but
looker when we looked at the looker
looker gave us a pretty good uh
functionality so you can embed those
reports uh into UI it also provides API
capabilities
and some of the obvious one which is
like it has very nice visualization tool
it has uh you can do Version Control on
your reports and their expert in
building
um uh the dashboarding so why not just
use them and they have very amazing
customer Supports as well
so this is the choices that we have made
um in in throughout the system that we
have built
so as we handle a vast amount of data it
becomes essential for our data platform
team to Monitor and alert
um and get alerts on this uh
like if if you detect any issues uh very
well and promptly right so to achieve
this we are using Prometheus uh grafana
cloud and pager Duty so Prometheus is
the one that collects all the metrics
from each application Aggregates them
and sends it to grafana Cloud
and uh we use Governor cloud alerting
services to uh send like pager Duty
alerts
we have many many alerts set up uh
through the system
these are just some of the example uh
that shows like like aging or messages
on the Kinesis stream right so you want
to make sure that if our messages are
staying for longer time on our Kinesis
we get alerted we have some capacity
alerts some pipeline failure alerts uh
that would be like real time telling us
uh something needs to be addressed
uh
what's coming next for us so as I
mentioned uh
we focus on scalability
um and and cost and effective cost
effectiveness
so
one of our application the consumer
application uh that we written on KCl
and uh Java Library we are on Java we
are uh seeing some performance issues
and now we are bringing we are looking
into the spark streaming uh last year we
started uh moving those consumer
applications to databricks spark
streaming and we are seeing pretty good
performance
um as well as the cost benefits as well
uh we're constantly looking into the
data quality and data observability so
that we are working with some vendors
doing POC uh and and and trying to bring
uh this very important I think that's
like a talk of
um this this conference like data
quality net observity is definitely
something that uh we are trying to uh
get into
uh
I would like to just end with
um this one statement that a key factor
in building a successful data platform
team is not having uh Army of
engineering team but
rather focusing on
um like create choosing appropriate
technology
and uh work on like differentiators uh
you need differentiators for your own
product so that's what we have been
doing and it's working out pretty well
for us
thank you